we will build roads rail energy and  Broadband quicker we will be proudly  pro-growth Pro aspiration and  pro-enterprise that is how we will Forge  ahead on our long-term path to National  success  in this new era we're taking a new  approach  my friends we're focused on boosting  growth and opportunity across our  country  this Mission will be difficult  but it is necessary  we have no alternative if we want to get  our economy moving again  I'm ready to make the hard choices  you can trust me to do what it takes  the status quo is not an option  that is why we can't give in to the  voices of decline we can't give in to  those who say Britain can't go faster we  can't give in to those who say we can't  do better we must stay the course  we're the only party with a clear plan  to get Britain moving we're the only  party with the determination to deliver  together we can unleash the full  potential of our great country that is  how we will build a New Britain for a  new era  foreign